Olá aqui Dr Machado Dutra eu sou médico
há mais de 25 anos e hoje eu vou
compartilhar com vocês informações
fantásticas sobre a creatina um dos
Suplementos mais estudados do mundo e
que muitos associam somente ao ganho
muscular Mas que também pode ter
benefícios surpreendentes pro cérebro
sim a mesma creatina que você já ouviu
falar das academias ela não é apenas um
suplemento para atletas de musculação
então Vamos explorar ar como ela pode
ajudar a melhorar a cognição humor
ansiedade e até mesmo tratar depressão
Quando pensamos em tratamento para
transtornos de humor como depressão e
ansiedade a creatina Não é a primeira
coisa que vem à mente correto Mas cada
vez
mais novas pesquisas sugerem que a
creatina pode desempenhar um papel
importante nesses problemas mas como é
que isso funciona a Teoria é que
condições como depressão ansiedade e até
demências podem diminuir os estoques de
creatina no cérebro eu aposto que você
não sabia desse fato que a creatina é
usada no cérebro ou que existe um
estoque cerebral de creatina Ok bem o
cérebro é um órgão altamente dinâmico
que utiliza e regula a energia biológica
do corpo para manter a suas funções
cognitivas e fisiológicas isso porque o
nosso cérebro é muito bioenergético e
depende bastante de creatina para
funcionar adequadamente e muitos estudos
atuais indicam que a suplementação com
creatina pode ajudar a repor esses
estoques cerebrais diminuindo os
sintomas de depressão e ansiedade além
disso a evidências de que a creatina
melhora memória e função cognitiva tem
quem diga Até que a creatina pode nos
deixar um pouco mais inteligentes mas
como é que a creatina age no cérebro o
nosso cérebro Ena creatina obtida
através da alimentação e da
suplementação a creatina atravessa a
barreira hematoencefálica ou hematol
clórico e aumenta os níveis de ATP que é
moeda energética e essencial para
processos celulares como a liberação de
neurotransmissores e o funcionamento
sináptico o cérebro sendo um órgão
intenso em uso de energia depende muito
desse ATP para suas funções e a creatina
armazenada como fosfocreatina nas
células atua como um reservatório pro
fosfato de Alta Energia o ATP que é
mobilizado rapidamente durante períodos
de alta demanda energética Então esse
mecanismo é bem importante PR os nossos
neurônios que T reservas limitadas de
energia em condições neurológicas como a
do SD parkson a creatina mostrou efeitos
neuroprotetores protegendo os neurônios
de várias formas de estresse a creatina
também pode influenciar nos
neurotransmissores incluindo as vias de
serotonina e de dopamina fundamentais
paraa regulação do humor então imagine o
impacto disso na qualidade de vida das
pessoas que lutam contra essas condições
isso é particularmente interessante para
mulheres mais velhas onde a
suplementação de creatina mostrou
melhorar o humor e a persistência em
tarefas intensivas pessoal a creatina
pode oferecer uma esperança adicional e
pode funcionar em conjunto com
tratamentos convencionais
potencializando os feitos além de
melhorar a função cognitiva a creatina
pode ajudar na redução dos níveis de
homocisteína o marcador associado à
depressão marcador inflamatório e também
de metilação a homocisteina alta pode
causar danos aos vasos sanguíneos e
promover inflamação afetando de forma
negativa o cérebro e tem estudos que
mostraram que altos níveis de
homocisteína podem levar a maior acúmulo
de placas betam milid no cérebro
característica da doença de alzheimer
além disso a miste Inna elevada está
associada ao estresse oxidativo e a
diminuição da síntese de
neurotransmissores essenciais fatores
que podem contribuir para o
desenvolvimento e Progressão de
depressão e demências os melhores
resultados da suplementação de creatina
pro cérebro foram mostrados em estudos
em adultos mais velhos Especialmente
quando o cérebro está sob estress então
em situações como privação de sono ou
tarefas mentalmente exaustivas a
creatina parece melhorar de forma
significativa a memória e a capacidade
de Recordar de reter informações eu vou
deixar os links para esses estudos na
descrição do vídeo para quem quiser se
aprofundar mais no assunto mas e quando
falamos de pessoas que não enfrentam
nenhuma doença
neurodegenerativa como as que Eu
mencionei para quem está sempre em
movimento enfrenta des fios diários como
executivos executivas lidando com prazos
apertados ou a mesmo estudantes passando
por desafios de privação de sono ou
ainda mães tentando equilibrar trabalho
e família a creatina pode ser um aliado
interessante ela ajuda a manter a mente
afiada melhora a capacidade de lidar com
o estresse e pode até aumentar
resiliência mental e não podemos
esquecer dos atletas entusiastas de
fitness para eles a creatina não Só
melhora o desempenho muscular Mas também
pode ajudar na recuperação mental após
treinos intensos manter a clareza e o
foco Mental é tão importante quanto a
força física e muitas modalidades
esportivas agora é importante lembrar
que a absorção de creatina pelo cérebro
é limitada em comparação com os músculos
para atravessar a barreira em Mato
encefálica ou hemato lcó de maneira
significativa são necessárias doses um
pouco mais maiores de creatina então
quando consumimos creatina 95% dela é
armazenada em músculos nos nossos
músculos Isso significa que menos de
5% vai para outras áreas do corpo
incluindo o cérebro por isso o acúmulo
de creatina no cérebro leva mais tempo e
pode exigir doses mais altas a
suplementação comum de creatina
geralmente envolve dos de 3 a 5 G ao dia
o que já traz muitos benefícios mas uns
estudos que focaram no tratamento de
doenças neurais foram necessárias doses
mais altas cerca de 10 g por dia para
ver benefícios substanciais no cérebro
esse tipo de utilização deve ser feito
com acompanhamento médico sempre Ok
quando utilizamos doses maiores de
creatina diariamente surgem algumas
preocupações com a creatinina creatinina
que é um marcador utilizado para avaliar
a função renal você já deve ter perfeito
esse exame de creatinina certo bem a
creatinina é um subproduto da degradação
da creatina fosfato nos músculos e é
filtrado pelos zins para ser eliminada
na urina com a suplementação de creatina
em doses mais altas os níveis de
creatinina no sangue Podem sim aumentar
no entanto esse aumento não indica
necessariamente um comprometimento renal
isso ocorre porque a creatina
suplementar é parcialmente convertida em
creatinina de forma não enzimática
independentemente da função renal em
outras palavras o aumento da creatinina
pode ser simplesmente um reflexo da
maior ingestão de creatina e sua
subsequente degradação e não um sinal de
que os zins estão com problemas para
filtrar essa creatinina para uma
avaliação mais precisa da função renal
em pessoas que estão suplementando com
doses mais altas de creatina a medição
da cistatina C pode ser uma alternativa
útil a cistatina c é uma proteína
filtrada pelos rins e não é afetada pela
suplementação de creatina sendo um
marcador mais específico e confiável da
função renal outra questão interessante
é que pessoas que seguem dietas com
baixo teor de carne como veganas ou
vegetarianas podem ter estoques mais
baixos de creatina no cérebro a
suplementação pode ser ainda mais
benéfica nos veganos e os efeitos
colaterais bem a creatina é geralmente
muito bem tolerada com poucos efeitos
adversos algumas pessoas reclamam pode
experimentar sintomas gastrointestinais
leves ou câimbras musculares mas esses
efeitos são geralmente superados pelos
benefícios potenciais especialmente um
tratamento de depressão e outros
distúrbios neurológicos eu tenho outros
vídeos bem interessantes sobre a
creatina um deles falando de todos os
seus benefícios e outro sobre as marcas
de creatina no mercado em termos de
qualidade links na descrição desse vídeo
Claro mais estudos clínicos são
necessários para determinar Protocolos
de suplementação ideais e confirmar
esses benefícios em diferentes
populações mas já temos muitos indícios
interessantes do seu potencial
Especialmente nos idosos Lembrando que
algumas pessoas reclamam de ficarem um
pouco inchadas com o uso da creatina mas
isso se deve à retenção de líquido
muscular isso não é necessariamente uma
coisa negativa comp os
vosem a alguém pode udar também no canal
da
alar Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração